en Syrie se sont encore des citoyens
ordinaires surtout qui travaillent dans
les décombres comme des forces aînées
pour dégager les victimes
hantée par les cris des survivants
coincés sous les débris
il lui dit il n'a pas peur nous je suis
là par le moi Dieu soit loué 30 heures
après l'effondrement de centaines
d'édifice les miracle sont encore
possibles
hurlé sortez-moi de la sortez-moi de là
il se corrige disent à l'enfant d'être
patient
n'y arrive pas j'ai mal écrit le jeune
qui a un bras blessé il finit par sortir
en boîte un peu une secours n'arrive pas
toujours à temps
ces hommes transportent un corps et le
dépose dans la boîte d'une camionnette
après le traumatisme de voir Céline
s'effondrer bien celui des deuils
multiples beaucoup ont perdu plusieurs
membres de leur famille
ils se coupent beaucoup plus de
dépouille que de survivre
ma mère était vivante dit-il mais là
elle est morte
et celle de faire son deuil ou de penser
ses plaies quand on est à la rue des
millions de Syriens sont sans abri ou
n'osent pas retourner dans des édifices
fragilisés les citoyens d'aleps sont
encore sous le choc celui de s'être
réveillé non pas sous les bombes cette
fois-ci mais dans une ville en ruine
franchement
on est fatigué franchement de cette
guerre et à la fin il y avait un petit
cadeau de tremplin
moi j'ai laissé ma famille dans la
voiture dans la rue
et
je suis parti tout de suite à l'hôpital
ce chirurgien
s'adapte d'opération serait occupée
toute la journée quand il est revenu
vers sa famille en soirée le père de
trois enfants a dû se trouver en refuge
les enfants psychologiquesment ils sont
pas assez forts pour rentrer à la maison
je refuse hier soir
refuge dans les écoles entre autres mais
ils sont déjà débordés on distribue
couverture trop d’hygiène ou et
nourriture mais les ressources sont
extrêmement limitées jusqu'ici presque
tous les dons à faire par les pays
riches sont destinés à la Turquie c'est
vrai donc il y a les moyens sont
beaucoup moins importants en série la
cheminement de l'aide et les extrêmement
compliquée donc effectivement le
transport aussi il y a des barrières
douanières l'impact des sanctions c'est
clair que ça joue les dons à se rendre
en Syrie en raison du le conflits et des
sanctions occidentales contre le
gouvernement de Bachar al-Assad l'Aïd
humanitaire est censée être exemptée
mais les obstacles demeurent nombreux
sacheuse art plus intime la dirigeante
d'Oxfam en Syrie explique que l'ail ne
peut arriver par avion car la plupart
des compagnies aériennes ne dessert plus
le pays en raison des sanctions les
marchandises arrivent au port de
Beyrouth et sont transportés par la
route les sérieux les plus vulnérables
ne reçoivent pas grand chose
[Musique]
c'est triste et elle jusque laisser le
peuple syrien comme ça des sanctions
sont contre le propre syrien qu'est-ce
que je vais dire aux patient un blessé
désolé j'ai pas de médicaments pour vous
est-ce que c'est humain ou pas
il ne s'est rien n'attendent plus l'aide
de l'extérieur Adama c'est dans les
autres villes qui sont intactes au Liban
aussi les gens font la file depuis hier
pour donner du sang et des biens
essentiels
Radio-Canada Montréal